per adesso non ho a cuore si no subito
abbiamo visto la sola più da chi
attenzione
siete pronti a lido della vita voi non
siete pronti al video della vita ma io
lo so che che siete pronti al video
della vita fa vj anima stefano su ben in
dead e dell ignoranza pura
buona visione non dico altro ci siete
accadendo cosa hai messo in testa su un
chip corvi a dire ora se famiglia tra il
problemi ai ragazzi vai sociali e ha
letto bene
corro dai bancari come ho perso
maledetti siringo siringo stefano che
devo fare
vieni posto e con la siringa postate
quale primo step one primo davanti senza
di voi non mi servite noto ha fatto come
ho fatto a morire ma geniale drogato dio
e la legge poi draga il primo che ci
arriva
cavalca fronte difficile governare
laggiù in fondo dai e di risaltare
schivare e non farli arrivare prima
degli altri la madonna che santo
geronimo qualcuno ok sono arrivato anche
io sono arrivato dobbiamo fare qua
saltano mai fatta salva voce arrivi c'è
un cucchiaio e non c'è ma [ __ ]
gravità amor questo gioco bellissimo
ascoltare con gli oggetti in mano e
santi normalmente madonna che porta
impresso ti schifo
no no io sono un ostacolo ragazzi meno
importante che fa di genova non può più
contare come il caso il cucchiaio ahia
ahia ahia
ti giuro
no non puoi spingere anche senza il
cucchiaio ai affaccia madonna che
fastidio mi lascio quando si perde no no
no io spero che il karma police cac
armati pulisca i corsi si creda mi ha
voluto da chiara ramagli ha pulito il
karma
adesso la plaza c'è poi da questo video
ma il family friendly barca era rimasta
davvero colpita non lo vota
eva è ripartita la gara non ce la farò
mai questo perché mi uccide vite
violetto sulle strade ditemi perché mi
odino a vicenda di morire l'uomo mi
aveva stato non sbagliare 1 st è morto
aia solo supporto modo vada andiamoci
essere stato porta sarà qua non ci posso
credere ma c'è a buffalo nel segreto ci
abbia fatto a tutti ma per oggi ai sic
ma che quello finale la grafia il corpo
e l'utile mani ha visto come chiari non
gli ha vinto quello è spettato merde
guerra eterna
ha vinto la gara 3 3 6 4 mentre voi
avete capito che è successo la mia testa
ha fischiato su playstation eye sotto
liberamente nel giro no sono morti ma io
non posso giocare così porca vacca
[ __ ]
davanti a loro spinta avanti come sta
sudando suda proprio personaggio di
lorenzo la marca o dio stava per morire
dove ce lo stava per morire hanno rapito
questa possibilità di abilità mimica che
arrivi alla fine e mi sconfiggere via
finale hai vinto tu se non ho vinto io
devo prendi tutto scajo è io sono col
cucchiaio d aspetto ed ora sono
schizzati un suo senza panino iniqua che
domina grande famiglia di schivarlo
rimane al gol
ho letto cose che succedono capito non
ho colpito è andato talmente in alto che
hanno superato traguardo arriva la
tutela dello spacco in faccia e vabbè
che non sei altro che mi guardi il
timing stefano cresta
no no no ma cosa voi va bene ci vado sul
finale misterioso e non salta sul primo
blu santa ci si va a fan culo bene
facciamo un altro di farci un culo così
ma è la madonna che il nostro no ragazze
le bombe il polacco è un versus anche ad
esaltarlo cioè a fuoco ovest e dentina
occhio del conosciuto
il ragazzo dopo mascara però lancia
testa dovevate c'è poi il lancio
lanciato lanciato lanciotto ci sono ci
sono
no sono morti un idiota storica vacca
che mi sono state di kamikaze sta
tornando è il sole bene cosa vuole
essere no aspetta ma maria ma io
schivata lager che io scriva tema si
rispose uno stage anche esatto macchia
che fastidio le ultime due lettere voi
pensa quello tu prendi tre e il cazzo
accesso nella tomba quella di parola sia
chi vince la testa finché mi fai ridono
ma le bombe la cosa sono grosse come
delle teste
sì ma c'è il fuoco non si sa nulla porta
da battere ci credo perché voi siete
presente se li fanno ragazzi sono di di
tris sul social
roma 3 maggio davanti al bari genoa sono
ad ora fatti complici sono che fastidio
nora gamacchio patologico ora cosa sta
parlando velocissimi ma stiamo battere i
giudizi si separò se fu il primo porca
vacca mate pavic e il suo gioco progetto
gioco battuto la privacy ed enzo gioco
batte free jazz ma tappa vicenda ma
togliti 26 ma si deve salire comporta
che se fastidio e dai dai che dovrebbe
operare raga peso
lo penso anch'io è politica
tagli di tutto io ora di avere cassano
chiedono dove per testare il possibile
studiare parma bersani maroni cose che
non c'entro niente
la stessa che ci prende 6 perché ce l'ha
fatta togliere il distacco a gli dite ce
l'ho fatta
come si salta scusano completare la gara
per la mia molto presto ho preso perché
preso gol
no nella stefano no muore subito abbiamo
vinto sono più da chi attenzione quanti
rodi abita maria e vittorio fatto non ci
posso credere come martelli playstation
popolare l'opera superare ma che cosa
vuole dal primo marzo era un pelo e sano
recuperatelo
non riesco gesù parlò di merda no mai
all'ultimo san marino credo a chi a tema
si voglia a chiara non lascia si no
ma lancia la testa non riesco mi ha
abbastanza che gara che gare credibile
la sise habría
allora scusate se ho interrotto il fatto
è che voi vi chiederete chi è che ha
vinto tra la fascia e stefano il
problema è che io dall'emozione perché
mi sto divertendo troppo a vedere sta
cosa con il ginocchio sinistro
ho schiacciato per sbaglio il tasto per
spegnere il computer e quindi mi si sono
interrotte le registrazioni e quindi
nessuno ha vinto in questo momento
mentre mi sono avvicinato dallo schermo
perché stavo crepando da ridere con il
ginocchio spi ha spinto il tasto dello
spegnimento del computer quindi si è
spento il computer con conseguenti
cristo nate da parte di stefano e sascha
che mi sono beccato ovviamente senza
registrare e vi lascio comunque al pezzo
finale che abbiamo registrato per
concludere perdonatemi sono stato un
idiota la prossima volta gioco con le
gambe incrociate perché non va bè
ginocchio schifoso ecco ci sono tornato
con la webcam scusato e tornato verdi
sono tornato merde sono subito cliccando
col tasto il compito dello spento avessi
casa e graziosa chalet stefano per aver
colpito forte i traguardi ma io ti
ringrazio un cazzo
non so che mi vuoi bene sa cos'è questo
gioco di merda un bacino servono ai
ragazzi passate anche nei canali sace
stefano che vi lascio nella descrizione
puzzle e che invece il giorno di caccia
che risolverete un'entità giusto che si
chiede perché il suo stava parlando
arabo
[Applauso]
[Musica]